today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza in Los Angeles
sometimes you'll you open your mouth and
there's nothing in there yeah well
what's that all about
change it up gray block pizza 18:11 Pico
Boulevard in Los Angeles get that hitter
you know every now and then an older man
will come into your life and uh kind of
teach you a little bit about yourself
you know teach you a little bit of
something teach how your skin feels a
little bit you know what I'm talking
about
teach you what's going on inside of your
body deep in there and that's what I'm
talking about today a lot of times if
you think about your stomach what the
[ __ ] is going on with it
so here today we have a beautiful man
and he's the author of the book grain
brain now he's a scientific kind of guy
so you know he in a juggle for us bro
but he'll definitely he has more
knowledge than I do and so that's why
I'm excited that he is here today he's
the author of grain brain which has more
than 1 million copies in print ladies
and gentlemen dr. Perlmutter
[Music]
so what is gluten dr. Perlmutter what is
it
so gluten is a protein it's found in
wheat barley and rye okay
and it's the rage right now and gosh we
wrote about it five years ago in grain
brain and at that point that was pretty
darn disruptive I want to tell you that
people suddenly you know you threaten
give us our day give us this day our
daily bread and people have a conniption
people trip out all my Jewish buddies
first started tripping they were like
the first friend that said they make
gluten-free matzah well they started
Luke like they were like losing it and
so then I was like what's going on here
you know and I mean I've read more about
it in your book but I just wanted to
hear like for a layman's like you know
like what if I saw gluten somewhere what
I know it's gluten no that's the thing
it's hidden in foods it's you know you
find it in condiments and ketchup you
find it all over the place
it's tricky it's like almost like um
who's that serial killer that they'd
have said that documentary come out
about I don't know but it's healthy it's
that Ted Bundy of uh oh gosh of the
bread program really I'm gonna have to
let you own that one
I'm not gonna go there but but that's it
I wouldn't say it as aggressive as Ted
Bundy but having said that it's it's
sinister it lurks in the background and
you know when you face all of the
chronic degenerative conditions that we
face now in this world the World Health
Organization tells us that chronic
degenerative conditions are the number
one cause of death on planet Earth we
have to ask ourselves what's the
mechanism there and the mechanism is
inflammation
okay what's causing inflammation high
sugar diet not enough fat things like
gluten food allergies those things
literally have to come off the table now
I was written in your book that um and
this is this blew me away that people
who have diabetes are twice as likely to
have Alzheimer's let's contextualise
that okay we live in a country where 5.4
million of us have already been
diagnosed with Alzheimer's yeah number
one number two there's no treatment none
whatsoever
and matter of fact in November of 1870
mout in JAMA the Journal of the American
Medical Association showing that the
drugs that doctors are using to treat
Alzheimer's are actually making them
worse well as opposed to neutral they're
actually declining more quickly so how
is that even a thing okay anybody could
make up that drug I'm a-gettin or worse
I would say what you just said that's
the whole show how is that a thing think
about it I mean yet you know there it's
proved by the FDA it's useless and in
fact making people words and people are
spending a billion dollars in America
yeah to buy these drugs putting their
faith into these drugs to help mom or
dad or husband or wife and I've been
there I've been there with my dad who
died about sighs yeah it was like yeah
my stepfather has it you know my mother
has two and it's horrible and it's
mostly preventable right and that's what
we shout about we shout about what you
said is that diabetes is related okay
you know when 80 million Americans are
diabetic or pre-diabetic it's not a
genetic issue all of a sudden that just
happened the past 50 years it's because
we've trained changed our diet now we're
eating more sugar and this is a disease
of sugar and refined carbohydrates and
less fat and all of a sudden everybody
becomes diabetic that may increase your
risk for an untreatable illness
Alzheimer's two to fourfold Wow then
you're really screwed so that's really
so if you have that in your family I
mean this these are really things you
need to look out for because Alzheimers
can take when does it usually kind of
strike people out armours the beginning
stages of Alzheimer's what sets the
stage for when you can't figure out
what's going on around you happens in
your 20s and 30s
that's your audience and that's a very
important concept yeah that it's not
when you're my age and you suddenly
can't remember the grandchildren's names
and you name it because that's what we
think it is I bet that's idea you're
already down the road yeah we a lot of
literature shows that if you look at
markers of inflammation in the blood
they predict Alzheimer's 30 years ahead
of time well and how do you get
inflammation markers in blood you eat
the wrong diet so it's not like
you know people say I had a heart attack
well it sound like you're walking on the
street minding your own business and
then all of a sudden this thing attacks
you either that's lightning yeah that's
it that's lightning right heart attack
happens because you ate the wrong foods
you didn't exercise you have some
genetic issues etc you set the stage for
a heart attack you set the stage for
Alzheimer's and I'm here to tell your
audience that there are changes to make
today yeah to lower your risk because
when you get there when you get to a
place where the doctor finally says
you've got this there's nothing you can
do yeah so yeah so it's one of those
things you have to start early yep and I
said 20s and 30s well when do you start
setting the stage for diabetes
adolescence childhood you said it when
you're born actually the changes begin
went before you're even born when you're
in utero depending on mother's lifestyle
choices has a huge role to play on
whether you're going to be diabetic
whether you're going to be overweight
which is a risk factor as well Wow
so so I'm just thinking of myself like
you know if I'm just hearing this you
know like a lot cuz a lot of our
listeners are twenty in their 20s and
30s and you know some of them may be
diabetic may not but they're usually a
lot of good people a lot of active
people that want to make their lives
better overall that seems to be our
audience so what are like some easy ways
out of the gate that you think you know
um is it just a rich thing as sometimes
I feel like just the rich can be able to
you know really have an insight it's
just the rich because you have to buy
something right yeah you got to go out
and buy a new pair of sneakers really
now I don't know how rich you have to be
or you get them out of a bin whatever
you need to do or you go barefoot the
bottom line is step one is you got to
exercise you got to get moving you got
to get your butt off the off the couch
and you've got to get at least 20 to 30
minutes a day of aerobics add some
resistance exercise of that fine but you
got to get your heart rate up and - what
number I don't know I usually tell
people 180 - your age do the math and
you can't do the math and you really
need to exercise you gotta move other
crews you bet you do and why do you want
to exercise well the relationship
between exercise if you look at the
epidemiology of it shows those people
who have higher rates of exercise have
lower rates of
but beyond that exercise changes gene
expression and codes for the body to
produce a chemical called BDNF that
tells your brain to grow new brain cells
who knew you know when I was I hate to
say when I was your age but when I was
your age we were told that we were given
a certain number of brain cells and then
as we every beer we drank 30,000 a
whatever was you whose X number of brain
cells coke cuz we didn't know that you
grow new brain cells yeah how do you
grow new brain cells by exercising by
taking a fish oil supplement by using
turmeric in your cooking this turns on
the gene pathway you can change your
gene expression grow new brain cells and
and stave off Alzheimer's what's so hard
about what I'm saying here right it's
really basic and so do you think there's
like a psychology to like sometimes
whenever you get into a path in life
whether it's an eating pattern or and
you know it's detrimental you know that
the end is heck doesn't end well is
there some term for a psychology that
makes you stay in that path almost out
of spite or something you know there are
a lot of terms one is mindset okay that
your mind is set in fact I had leaned up
at the interview this morning and the
question was how does mindset come into
play for health health decisions your
mind isn't set you can change your mind
and the more you change your mind and
then do the right thing the better that
pathway becomes the more reinforcing it
will be the other thing I talk about is
Inconvenient Truth you know Al Gore
talked about the Incas the climate
change men are yeah I did a CBS this
morning program a couple of months ago
and they said no dr. Perlman has a new
book there's a new book talking about
gluten and carbs and all that but we
reached out to the sugar industry and
they told us we should eat more sugar
because decades of research and in my
mind it was hashtag why that's fantastic
hashtag WTF right why that's fantastic
yeah okay good so in my might and then
then the lady gets on she said this
morning I had well last night I had
truffles because they're in season
truffle pasta with a jelly filled donut
or
and again it's an inconvenient truth
what I'm saying to your audience today
is an inconvenient truth why cuz we all
have a sweet tooth oh you all would love
to eat sweet dude duh it's comfort food
because it stimulates the part of the
brain for instant reward dopamine surge
and your momentarily content but oddly
enough that diet distances you from the
executive center of the brain that lets
you make better decisions plan for the
future be more compassionate and
empathetic for yourself for the next
person and for the planet Wow so the
more we distance ourselves from
impulsivity the better decisions we'll
make we'll get on an exercise regimen
we'll stay on it and we'll choose to eat
better foods that will enhance that
feed-forward that's really interesting
because be so because impulse is that
it's that it's almost just like that
it's like that dirty magnet that's in us
and it just wants whatever the kurt
whatever the easiest quickest hit is
done and then you need more of it Rachid
need more of it because it's a dopamine
surge stimulates the opiate receptors in
your brain done
you know you you've done your thing and
now you need more and the more you do it
the more that receptor needs to be
stimulated and so choice is almost
behind impulse a little bit I mean it's
right there with it but it's almost a
gift or outride the impulse I feel like
exactly a bit for a second and then be
able to that's what I feel for me it's
like okay I just need a second and make
a choice the moment you just did that
well you just did Theo is you stopped
dealing and and responding to your
amygdala brain your reptilian brain that
said I'm gonna eat this a sugar lizard
conscious guy and instead I'm gonna
decide that one moment is all the
difference in the world I'm gonna think
about do I really want to eat this do I
really want to whatever the addiction
may be yeah but I really wanted to this
and now make a more sophisticated more
human rational decision to not do it
you've broken the spell you can move
forward Wow and does that get easier
over time do absolutely we talked about
the growth of new brain cells yeah the
same chemical brain derived neurotrophic
factor BDNF that you get from exercise
okay stimulates what we call
neuroplasticity
that allows you to connect to that part
of your brain so these things then stick
and the more they stick the better you
get at it's like learning to hit a
tennis ball and then the better you feel
about them does that impulse ever switch
to the other yes we need the other
impulse you need the other impulse
because when you're back in your car out
of the driveway and your mind sees in
the backup camera a little kid on her
bike you hit the brake yeah you don't
think well I probably a good idea to
write the old brake pedal because this
is gonna turn out bad so that's when the
lizard really helped you bet you need
that you need that impulsive activity to
make the right decision quickly but you
don't need it when you're trying to
figure out what foods to buy in the
grocery store can I make an excuse and
not exercise today you know exercise is
something that we don't have to we don't
want to find time for it we want to make
time for it if you have to find time you
said well I'll squeeze it in between
such and such and such and such and then
those things suddenly take over a little
more time you didn't exercise you didn't
meditate you didn't take time to make
the food that's good for you ate some
crap that you you know fast food yeah
you know I'm thinking is not good then
it's like are you know it's really we're
kind of in a tough it's a tough system
it's like we've created this you know
this sort of I don't know if it's a
comfort society or or what it is but
it's I mean the system that we're in in
a lot of places now I'll say in LA it's
easier it's very easier it's much easier
for me to stay healthier here it really
is then if I'm back in other place like
I'm from Louisiana if I'm there it is
tough for like you know sometimes it's
just tougher sathya my team said you got
to watch these a couple of his podcast
for it come on your show right and I I
got a tie this is there's no segue here
whatsoever but that's what this is about
right and I didn't know what to expect
but I'm enjoying the heck out of this is
great are you oh absolutely
good man yeah well look I'm super
curious me one of the main reason we'll
get to it is you know I take
antidepressants and a lot of times I get
tired of you know it makes me feel like
there's this you know there's something
that's not natural that's out there
that's added disconnect this this
to me this yeah this this chain you know
it's like almost I'm a slave in a way to
it a lot of times and eventually maybe
one day I would like to maybe not take
them now I'm not asking you for that you
know direction now but I do think I
start thinking well where my other
brains in my body you know and so then I
start thinking about my stomach you know
it's almost shaped in a way like you
know it's you know your organs are
almost like in a way for to me or in my
imagine it's a way I work off of
imagination first kind of it kind of is
like a brain something well how can I
learn more about like what I put in my
stomach that could then affect how my
brain behaves and so then I was talking
to my producer Nick and I was like we
got to get somebody that knows about
this so that I can learn more about it
you know and so that's basically where I
started thinking about you know about
having you on and then I only read about
60 pages of grain brain but it was
really fascinating to me even in that
little bit of time I found some things
that are really interesting and so I'm
glad you're today so I can talk to you
about them well who knew yeah I mean who
knew that food has such an effect on
every aspect of our lives let me get
back to the imagination part cuz I was
really taken by that you know
imagination is only a manifestation of
connecting things that really happened
right you know your reality comes
together to form imagination and in many
ways interesting well it is I mean
you're a new your neurologist first
right first I'm I think that assessment
and father okay there you go
there we go that's good but yeah I'm in
neurology so so you know about the brain
I know a little bit about the brain yeah
who knew yeah but I would say that so
imagination it is sort of like what
happens during sleep so during sleep we
connect real events real memories and
form and we measure them against each
other we form new ideas right so
imagination is based upon your reality
things that you have experienced or have
imagined in the past those things were
based on things that you have
experienced Wow and let's get back to we
this connection of the gut to the brain
not just the stomach right which
interesting I've never heard anybody say
was shaped you were about to say and
don't put words your mouth looks like
the brain a little yeah
yeah maybe if I didn't say yeah so are
pecans
yeah good wall huh - right but but that
said depression is an inflammatory
disorder now I want that to sink in it's
a disease characterized by higher levels
of chemicals in your body that relate to
a process called inflammation yeah now
you're familiar with inflammation you
get bitten by a mosquito your hand gets
inflamed yeah but those same
inflammatory chemicals are upped amped
up in your body in relation to
depression relation to Alzheimer's
autism Parkinson's coronary artery
disease diabetes cancer all those things
have inflammation along inflammatory
disorders Wow which are so fundamentally
related to not just your gut and things
going on there knowing that your gut
bacteria determine what is called the
set point of inflammation in your body
but even more importantly to your food
choices because you have to understand
you know they say that when a woman is
pregnant she has to be careful now she's
eating for two yeah I've heard that Theo
you're eating for a hundred trillion
right as of the future month its semen
all of that know your gut bacteria oh I
see what you're saying
so they're eating what you had for
breakfast today oh those hundred
trillion bacteria floating around your
gut what's yo gonna eat today and is it
is it a fiber rich good food that we're
gonna be thrilled about we're gonna
replicate we're gonna put out great
chemicals we're gonna control the
production of his brain chemistry right
yeah that's fascinating we'll get back
to that because you mentioned that
earlier that the things you eat affect
emotionally how you're able to be to
relate to other people is that actually
that research was done right here in LA
dr. Amer and Mayer did some of the
pioneering work on that you write that
down Tamra Mayer and made guy to have on
the show Cameron
you owe me one Wow because so I could
potentially be able to love people
better and learn about myself better if
I eat better I will tell you without a
doubt so here's what we need to craft
for you we need to craft for you a diet
that reduces inflammation yeah
fundamentally we reveal enflamed well
why do we see other
inflammatory disorders along with
depression why do we see skin
inflammation joint inflammation those
types of things
obesity which is an inflammatory
disorder the inflammation comes from fat
cells Wow
so why do these things all happen why do
we see gross disturbances of gut
bacteria because they're all related so
the trick then for you and any of the
other 47 million 27 million Americans
are suffering from depression what do we
offer up we offer up a diet that's lower
in its ability to produce inflammation
okay and that is a diet that's lower in
sugar lower and refined carbs but has
fiber which is a carbohydrate
fundamental point here people say I'm
going on a low-carb diet and they ditch
the fiber because it's a carb by
definition right it's a last thing in
the world you want to do you want to
nurture your gut bacteria don't get rid
of the fiber you need that and dare I
say eat more fat eat olive oil avocado
oil avocados nuts and seeds grass-fed
beef wild fish get good fat calm the
fire who knew now if you really want to
push it and you're you look like you
probably want to push it right I think
so I don't know well let's find out how
old are you I'm 38 okay third your
birthday's tomorrow yep my birthday's
tomorrow be 39 why are you I'm gonna be
39 tomorrow okay so you do you want to
look into Quito you really want to look
into the ketogenic diet would do you a
world of good but be sure and to any of
your listeners viewers who are thinking
key or key toward doing keto you've got
to eat the fiber or you'll get
constipated you'll have digestive issues
and you gotta use potassium and
magnesium or you'll get the keto flu
okay so many people bail on the keto
diet because they don't do those two
things okay so so you're saying so a way
to kind of to start in the fast track
some of the things that you've been
talking about that will help your system
and my system great pun there fast track
you want a fast yeah yeah you want a
fast oh you want a fast you want a fast
do you want it fast well for all them
first time because I'm slow so I have to
go through
I'm sure a lot quicker maybe there they
always say I'm repeating stuff but so so
a keto diet that we also add potassium
and magnesium supplements now that could
be vitamins we could get those in a
store yeah I mean there are things there
online brands that you can get and
that's okay to add to it with the kids
don't have to so a keto diet with those
and then also fiber now can that fiber
be a supplement as well or does the
fiber I always choose food first okay
all right so if we're talking about
magnesium let's be a little bit
technical here so chlorophyll was what
makes things green hmm the center of the
chlorophyll molecule right is magnesium
so anything green that you eat has
magnesium and that's okay way to know so
you want to get diversity you want to
get lots of color you want to eat a lot
of vegetables they have a lot of fiber
if you really want the right kind of
fiber for your gut bacteria you use what
is called prebiotic fiber that's onions
garlic sleet's
leeks chicory root oh that's in
Louisiana all the call very girly in it
that they dilute it in the day
especially in World War two but
dandelion green but you can go to the
health food store and say stand at the
counter say I want some prebiotic fiber
I'm not saying probiotics prebiotics and
they have prebiotic fiber that's made
from acacia gum that's the tree in
Africa it secretes this gum sustainably
harvested it's the best prebiotic you
can find dang organic it secretes it's
got us twice chewed then if you get it
you know hmm I guess it might be a bad
joke oh but we do though is we can put a
list of like a basic kind of starter set
up a diet in this under this you tube
that would be I think really helpful to
people but let's talk about more that
involves inflammation yeah yeah but you
can leverage for depression okay okay so
one do everything we can tie it is key
okay exercise twenty minutes of aerobics
a day key being on schedule is really
very important trying to do the same
thing every day that you possibly can
not just what you eat but when you eat
try to eat your last food at least three
hours before you go to bed okay yeah so
you want to be sleeping on your sleeping
digesting during
times that you're awake you want to make
sure you're getting good restorative
sleep like eight hours a night that
would be really important and dare I say
you want to limit stress and what does
it mean everybody's talking about I want
to limit stress so I don't do certain
things I don't engage in certain things
stress can be watching the evening news
stress can be on social media where
we're being told we're not good enough
yeah because social media pounds you
with ideology that we're not measuring
up that everybody else's life is better
you look at their Instagram posts
they're having the best time why is my
life not so great so stop comparing
ourselves to other people that will look
that's the biggest stress inducer I
think of in our modern time so get
that's an Austin of this merry-go-round
where everybody else looks like their
have I got news for it they honored
right they're all having a great time
their lies are wonderful they aren't if
they're not sharing the truths a lot of
times yeah which would probably if they
did it might even alleviate some
people's stress to know that that we
aren't the same do you really so you
really yeah I guess in your lifetime
you've probably seen and I don't think
you're much older than me but I bet in
your lifetime that you've seen has that
really shocked you the the way that
social media stuff has has become that
much of a stressor absolutely and I'm
I'm a lot older than you I'm 64 so you
look good for 64 I'm trying yeah
it has shocked me and my son Austin
Pearlman are also an MD to the extent
that we've written a book about it well
and that's coming out in January of 2020
called brainwash a we're calling
attention to this issue and B we're
providing the response what you can do
to offload this stuff yeah how you could
sleep better
why exercise is important how the food
that you eat speaks to your genes giving
your genes information to reduce
inflammation or increase inflammation
your choice based upon what you eat but
to identify this very obvious way that
we are being manipulated on social media
and in our digital world not just for
producing this feeling of low self-worth
but providing the the quick clickbait
answer to satisfy look
I'm overweight by this thing lose weight
quickly and all these ideas feel quick
and sudden that's redundant ways to
satisfy ourselves getting back to the
impulsive 'ti part of the brain where
we're saying look stop if you think you
need to buy stuff every day on Amazon
because that makes you feel better stop
wait 24 hours and then buy it if this is
a quick fix for your problem take a deep
breath and but don't be misled by what
you're seeing on digital media as to
what your value is hmm so Facebook
shouldn't determine Theo's value what
you think of yourself right you talk
about depression what goes on in terms
of manipulating your online choices is a
situation that absolutely creates
depression and so like give me an
example of that so what goes on is like
like the things that I do online and how
I behave on there and what I see on
there you mean can immediately make me
feel a certain way absolutely because
what it's doing is its catering your
brain to continued relationship with the
amygdala the reptilian brain immediate
response you feel bad about yourself for
this by that and you're done
you've satisfied that you get the
dopamine hit as soon as it arrives the
next day on Amazon Prime or they drop it
into backyard with a drone or however
the near new way of you satisfying that
urge and then it came and you suddenly
realize I need more it's I'm not content
whereas contentment means you have
enough yeah that's the prefrontal cortex
you have achieved a place where you
don't need more you've achieved a place
of happiness of empathy and compassion
for other people of being able to calm
yourself and make appropriate decisions
about your life and meet make decisions
about your life and about caring for
your neighbor about caring for people
who are different than you are and about
caring for the planet Wow
so that kr it's amazing that so much
emotion can come from from what we eat
and then it can I could definitely see
how like if you had less inflammation
you'd probably so less inflammation
means less
yes absolutely okay and so let's stress
of course you then you're going to be
it's gonna be easier for you to be
patient with someone it's gonna be
easier for you to be more understanding
it's gonna be easier for you to to take
that extra second to like kind of make a
choice so you're not just being that
reptile but it sounds it seems like all
the advertising and everything these
days were like catapulting humanity
towards just using that reptilian brain
that's right so we've got to stop that
do you think we can I'm gonna do my best
and our an Austin Perlmutter is doing
his best to put the information out
brainwash about what people can do and
you know one other really important part
of the program is reconnecting with
nature and that can be having a plant in
writing you when you're doing a podcast
or can be walking in nature and
breathing better air what about candles
even unnoticed when I have candles
around that I feel so much different
than when I no candles are a visual we
were attracted to fire it's very calming
but in addition there are sense of
candles which hopefully are natural and
that's one of another reason that
forests being in the forest really
reconnect us that's a very deep and
primitive part of our brain that you're
activating yeah man it's crazy to think
kind of like just where we're headed
then you know I read in your book that
there's like sometimes you think like
okay I'm having this thing that my
ancestors had this primitive sort of
diet and it was about wheat a part of it
was about a wheat or something but that
the wheat that we have now is nothing
like the act the wheat that they had
then well and I might be paraphrasing
let's put in perspective our ancestors
didn't have wheat okay so wheat only
came into the picture 14,000 years ago
to be generous mm-hmm
which means for ninety nine point six
percent of our time walking this planet
we didn't have wheat Wow
we didn't have barley we didn't have any
of that stuff I mean that's when
agriculture began and you know the the
size of the buret our brain increased
threefold from two million years ago up
until about 14,000 years ago and then a
stop
then it's declined 10% so yes so think
about that so you know everybody pray
that's correct
ready credits agriculture with you know
with all these great events advances in
humanity you know the development of
cities and and our social true social
networking but in reality it has
represented the greatest change in human
diet ever so you know that's sort of
segues to the so called paleo movement
and yeah I think to grasp that you
really have to understand that food is
information what do I mean by that that
the foods you eat yeah it nurtures your
gut bacteria we talked about that which
is hugely important in and of itself but
it also sends important information
about your environment to your DNA you
are controlling the expression Wow DNA
based upon the foods that you eat so if
I eat healthy stuff I'm letting my DNA
know that I'm in a healthy environment
and that everything is okay and your DNA
creates antioxidants right it helps
Hills out it's a bi it makes chemicals
to grow more brains yes and it makes you
feel better about the world whereas if I
have two boxes at art and Tiny's and
then my DNA says Jesus Christ
I don't know tart and tiny just like a
um it sounds back an e not a turtle tiny
didn't grow in nature yeah sweet tart
sweet tart yeah for this or sugar
tootsie rolls yeah you know you reach
them back Milk Duds
mekka wait dude that's crazy
ROH I know we should take a poetic Basel
but so when you do that you eat that
food so you have the artificial colors
artificial flavors lots and lots of
sugar yeah that sends signals to your
DNA that amplifies the production of
inflammatory chemicals reduces your
production of antioxidants and
compromises your detox pathways so
you're eating poison and at the same
time you're compromising your ability to
get rid of poison so you're setting
yourself up for disaster now when can
you have some poison like wink can you
like sometimes look man I've been on a
flight to New York and I'm
by that Dunkin Donuts brah gotta have
one you know I can't even and they got
the lake over there look out ladies
there's a lot of advertising three or
four different colors rim them bright I
want you two to realize to take a step
back and think that that's playing on
you that's playing on that quick
dopamine surge are they kidding it was
in charge that lizard that's what you
asked yourself what I do look for a
mirror look your self in the mirror look
in your eyes and ask yourself one
question who's in charge gonna larry
dunk and usually bra go straight right
at me okay don't get me though a lot of
times things don't get me but can you
celebrate once in a while mean you can't
absolutely I mean do you ever celebrate
like who have a birthday cake if it's
someone's birthday not so much right
that you know my cells didn't know that
it's your birthday tomorrow they don't
know that yesterday was st. Pat whatever
is like holiday your everyday could be a
holiday I'm sure every somebody's
birthday every day right yeah your cells
don't know it's Thanksgiving or
Christmas they don't take the day off
right so again you know from my
perspective having dealt with patients
and their maladies for all these years
having having dealt with a father who
died of an illness that's related to
lifestyle choice and my mother as well
as a cigarette smoker I realized that
your choices matter all lack of a lot
when Theo says you look younger than 64
I'm thinking keep at it you know stay
with it yeah and but beyond that get the
message out do the best you can to get
the message out for other people because
people are absolutely struggling yeah
you walk through that airport whatever
time it is you look at what people look
like a most people are overweight yeah
and look awful and be they're not happy
yeah and see what I've learned and what
was motivation for this new book is
people are lonesome and unconnected yeah
that's we talk about a lot in here do
what we we can to let people feel
comfortable with reconnecting to others
who are different from them who look
different whose ideas are different and
we stop we listen to what that person
has to say you know you ever heard this
saying you know it you if you're going
to
judge somebody you have to walk a mile
in their shoes before you say something
about yeah you know why they say that
because then when you judge them you're
already a mile away right and you have
their shoes you know I like that how
where do you go we're doing that I
stumped you yeah I think I am stumped so
now you talked about prebiotics earlier
and we'll put a we'll put a couple of
those on and you can go to your health
store and ask what they are so you
recommended for kind of not a fast track
but to get started in a place that would
have a diet that is better for you that
would cause less stress and cause less
inflammation in your body would be a
keto diet with magnesium and potassium
supplements and some prebiotics that
would be a great start lots of fiber
yeah now after you to start this what
are signs that you could look for that
it's having an effect in your life and
that happens quickly why are usually a
couple of weeks you wake up refreshed
you want to open the curtains and let
the light in so many things that we
could talk about in terms of that keep
that in mind but people feel better more
energetic clearer of mind you know a lot
of people don't realize they're a bit
foggy until suddenly the fog I've
realized that all the time yeah
sometimes I'm like man what is it's like
there's this kind of smog in my head and
it really feels physically like that
like a very thin smoke helmet exactly
and I don't use drugs or alcohol well in
in the day we used to listen to FM radio
a lot yeah
and now everything is course digital but
it on an FM on FM radio you'd be driving
your car and if there is lightning you
couldn't even see if it was way out in
the distance somewhere that would strike
you would hear it on the radio that the
music would be interrupted you hear the
sound and that's what inflammation does
to your thought process when you've got
high levels of inflammation in your body
it's like that lightning going off in
the background and the music gets
interrupted so when the inflammation
starts to get toned down your memory
improves and you start to see things
clearly the fog will lift what happens
quickly then the weight loss begins and
people look at the mirror and notice
their face looks better people comment
the you go to your next belt loop hole
in your belt and and people start to
feel better and it doesn't take long and
what's good about that is
let's say takes two weeks that is
self-reinforcing I'm doing it I'm
finally I'm not doing it how good is
that I am not on a diet it's not X Y Z
diet we buy a book or go on whatever it
is I don't have to go to meetings I'm
just eating the right foods my body is
responding because your body wants to be
healthy yeah it wants to resist disease
your brain wants to work your brain
wants to resist disease and your mood I
think your body your brain wants you to
be happy yeah you were gifted this
lifetime and you were gifted I believe
the the desire and the ability to enjoy
life and not be depressed yeah
depression happens when things line up
and then it's feed-forward the more
depressed you are the less likely you
are to exercise the less likely you are
to make the right food choices yeah
with all due respect the more likely you
are to give in to Dunkin Donuts or
whatever else is bombarding your mind
with ideas that this is what you should
do for that immediate surge that glazed
doughnut that's going to give you that
dopamine surge that then stimulates your
endogenous opiate receptors and I
believe that that is a big player in
terms of opiate addiction that we
constantly bombard ourselves with first
the dopamine surge all right it then
makes these opiate receptors want more
already and of course then there's
opiates
there's opioids yeah they're they're
ready mailing snackable snack-sized now
me yeah back in the day you to smoke
opium you know and now they got a little
snack they got the may pills yeah vape
in practically I mean I'm surprised
opioid hadn't come out with a and there
a and I like the 8c products that are
shaped like pacifiers what is the signal
we're sending to children their infants
yeah I mean that's certainly an adult
play toy Oh toddlers are sleeping for
three days on some of these pacifiers
you know I want to get back to here
really great the kids sleep in
everything's good we can go home at
least have a kid we go over to his house
his boy Jeff Soviet and they had a gas
leak in their house right and nobody
ever knew and we would go over there and
go to sleep we'd sleep on Friday we go
to sleep on Friday night like 2:00 a.m.
you
we get up Sunday morning man we'd sleep
for like 32 hours we had no idea that
they had a whatever kind of gas that is
you know when I hold Jeff so VIX doing
these days
I don't know where he is an actually
I've tried to text him and call him so I
wish you would reach back Jeff is out
there baby
we didn't update do we would sleep
forever man his whole family be asleep
you walk by his mom we making a salad to
just be on comments really like yeah
they had like a I guess it's carbon
monoxide or something something in their
house usually it's it's a pretty much
more aggressive kind of event that
happens with carbon monoxide as opposed
to going on for year after year but
could be yeah it must been it might have
been like a slow leak or whatever but
yeah but it was relaxing but anyway we
had mentioned about you know you wake in
the morning throw open the curtains get
a lot of light in and I do so you'll
naturally start to do that oh yeah Wow I
I think the light story is something we
can touch on since we're there there's
not huge segues here ya know we don't
and sometimes we never know how these
conversation to go it's like sometimes
it's you know you just never know and
that's what our list that's what podcast
listeners and I enjoys a listener is
just you know two people talk and they
don't know each other and and you know
one of them having information about
something in one of them not you know
well I'd say that you know we're just
really getting a handle on how circadian
rhythms affect the human body right and
we be you know we're really realize that
every cell in our body is response to
the circadian day circa around dia day
okay Hadean rhythm that it's all of
ourselves including our gut bacteria
respond to various times of the day
there's a great book called their
circadian code by dr. Sachin Panda great
be a great guest for you but nonetheless
I mean he talks about how it's really
important for us a Matthew Walker to for
his book why we sleep mm-hmm oh yeah I
actually read about half of that book on
Joe Rogan I think yeah yeah but about
you know that we need to have blue light
during the day that we should get out
and experience blue light really have
exposure to to bright sunlight because
that really will tamp down melatonin and
then in the evening time we want to back
down off blue light significantly and
where are we getting blue light I mean
these LEDs are we're loading ourselves a
blue light
we are but we don't want to do that at
nighttime because that would suppress
melatonin and keep us from getting
restorative sleep very underrated in
terms of how important that is for you
for reducing cortisol surges for
reducing inflammation so getting what we
call salubrious or restorative sleep is
incredibly important and it's underrated
I mean you spend a third of your life
hopefully sleeping yeah and what about
this melatonin supplements those are
okay to take I think they are yeah but I
would say before we supplement it would
be good to do it more naturally right
and recognize what is it that allows
melatonin to be present or absent and
it's mostly blue light light so that get
a lot of blue light in the daytime
evening comes around you want to back
down if you're gonna be on your computer
or looking at your iPhone or whatever
phone you may have you put on Amber
glasses because I blocked blue light and
is very very helpful in terms of
allowing your brain then to make more
melatonin allowing you to get some
restorative sleep now yeah you may have
sleep apnea you may have periodic leg
movements that are waking you up but
yeah the legs I do I got checked for the
sleep at me I don't have it yeah but you
may have leg movements that wake you up
so you're getting into deep sleep but
then your legs start to move around you
get into a lighter stage of sleep that's
not as restorative how would you know
yeah that's where I've spent a lot of
time yes you may not know that that's
why you get a sleep study you go into a
lab and they went there
yeah and it's it's a little odd it was
craziest it was flirting with me this
was that light I had a guy started
crying yes like we're dying
I know knee and they got cameras
watching but anyway it's worth doing I
mean you know there is are there other
things like the aura ring is a great
thing I'm gonna hope get mine in the
next couple of weeks and raise that and
or ring you put on your hand you wear it
all the time measures your level of
activity but is able to measure the
depth and quality of your sleep you wake
up in the morning this thing downloads
into your phone and tells you hey you
got X number of hours in this stage of
sleep in that stage of sleep and then
you know you work with it seems reliable
that piece actually I'm interviewing the
president of that found God you weren't
good the founder of that company next
week and gonna learn more about it so
I'm very excited about it
yeah there anything that you can learn
that can hack your body and give you
tools I'm all about I'm gonna do that I
mean that's going on we have so much
information yeah I think get your
23andme or other online a company
that'll give you a report of your genome
you need that information you can do
great stuff with once you take that data
download it to one of many different
sites I recently downloaded mine to
found my fitness that's Rhonda Patrick
great site and I learned stuff about
myself that I think is really important
I learned for example that I don't
metabolize or use B vitamins very
effectively I have to have a special
type of B vitamin called methylated B
vitamins I never would have known it Wow
so who knew and but do you find that
like sometimes I worry that get like the
information like sometimes you use an
app when I go run or something and
getting that information it takes the
joy out of doing the task do you ever
find that is that just some way my brain
is no no I think there's been a lot of
pushback and I think there has to be
some level of temperance as it relates
to that I mean I don't run with an app
hmm I don't run with us a special watch
and so I don't know unless I'm training
for an event having said that I do want
to know my miles my minutes per mile
right
but otherwise I don't get involved in
that I do like to listen to music so I
find that really helpful or podcast when
I'm running but I think that you people
can overdo it there's there's been
pushback with a lot of these things that
measure all these parameters that it's
way too much it's information overload
right but I will say that knowing your
genome once is a good bit of information
to have okay because you could take that
information and dump it onto any number
of sites and learn some stuff about
yourself that's really gonna turn out to
be helpful and you know how can you
learn about your genome 23andme okay fit
in a you know yeah I did that so I got
it yeah you get back your data yeah but
that doesn't really helpful then you
take your data you drag it on your
desktop this says Theo's data right here
then there any number of sites one of
them is found my fitness Rhonda Patrick
yeah great guys dr. Rhonda Patrick right
John Rogan a bunch yeah now we almost
reached out to her one time
you should reach out I got connected to
her this morning nice only I mean I'll
ask her if it's okay to connect with you
she yeah terrific
the interest at you take your you go to
her website you drag the file you drop
it next thing you know you get a report
and her algorithm tells you various
things that you need to know about
yourself
Wow how you handle dietary fat what
level of various activities you could
engage in what are your how do you
handle B vitamins fascinating yeah there
are a lot of those sites do they tell
you it's great to have the data you know
your who your ancestors were you know
what percentage of your genome is
Neanderthal how is that helpful I don't
know yeah but beyond that there's a lot
of stuff you should know that we can use
yeah especially begin there's another
way it's just interesting no there's
another way to use that information
because I don't even know that I'll help
you with it okay cool yeah no that'd be
awesome
I had a I just wanted to know a little
bit more about do you think that people
could eventually I mean obviously you
know this is some people always you need
to discuss with their doctors but get
off of an enterprise knew you're going
there and I would say that let's make
this our goal you and I yeah get you off
of medications will work give it a year
okay all right how cool would it be for
you on your program to see you know I've
been off whatever it is you I don't have
you told your audience what you think
yeah I think I don't yeah I just switch
to something else vibrate or something
so how cool would that be that you said
did this this and this and I've been off
my antidepressant for X period of time
I'll try you'll work with your doctor
I'm your doctor but we'll talk about
some lifestyle issues that may pave the
way for letting that happen or not Wow
dude that's are you easy I guess I'm in
it would be silly for me to say I'm not
in you know I'm always talking about
doing things different and taking some
contrary action so I'm ready to do it I
think maybe that's even while you're you
know one of the reasons you know for me
while you're here today
you know II know selfishly but that be
also ly reasonable you're not the only
one who's watching this that's a good
point
last weekend is brought to you by a
skill share now if you think of somebody
who can't do something you ever see
somebody what are they doing nothing
loitering maybe just sitting there just
hanging out with gravity that's nothing
well that person needs a skill go tap
him on the shoulder say hey buckaroo
you should be doing something Skillshare
is an online learning community for
creators with more than 25,000 classes
and design business and more you'll
discover countless ways to fuel your
curiosity creativity and career take
classes in social media marketing mobile
photography creative writing or even
illustration whether you're looking to
discover a new passion start a side
hustle or gain new professional skills
we're talking professional skills think
of somebody that's a professional a
doctor a dancer a you know someone who
makes cement Skillshare is there to keep
you learning thriving and reaching those
new goals join the millions of students
already learning on Skillshare today
with a special offer just for our
listeners we need skills so go to skill
share and get two months of skill share
for free that's right skills share is
offering our listeners two months of
unlimited access over 25,000 classes for
free go to Skillshare comm slash Theo
von th EO vo in no spaces again go to
skills share comm slash Theo von to
start your two months now that skill
share calm slash Theo von gang we had a
couple questions to from listeners that
called in so let's get to a couple of
those
what's up the Oh dr. Perlmutter Gang
Gang Gang bud coming at you from an oil
rig in Oklahoma
yeah I'm reading the book right now
grain brain really interesting stuff not
all the way through it so I apologize if
I say anything wrong but but you know
then I go on the news or something then
I find the Northwestern study about eggs
and cholesterol and how it's linked to
heart disease so my question is just
kind of how do we sift through what's
good knowledge and bad knowledge how do
we kind of get to the bottom of it but
thanks for coming on the show thanks for
talking about it it makes a lot of sense
I'm really enjoying the book so y'all
take it easy
thank you know the Gangnam what's his
name bad bad been so been asked a great
question so a study just came out saying
that higher levels of cholesterol
consumption or egg consumption are
linked to all cause mortality as well as
risk for coronary vascular disease so
after bad again pardon me eggs are bad
again let me let me finish because uh a
higher egg in cluster consumption hikes
heart disease have a half of omelet in
me right now yeah me too okay and let's
talk about that what does it mean how
did they do the study they did they
asked people what do you eat mm-hmm
which is notoriously and interesting
maybe not the best way of determining
what people are truly eating people want
to answer the questions really want to
lie and they determine cholesterol
consumption based upon certain their
frequency of consuming foods higher in
cholesterol and we think it's a good
study I think it tells us some important
information but it doesn't address
quality the quality of the eggs that
people consume is very important oh real
there is no alchemy that happens when
chickens eat garbage in a factory and
then produce eggs and if if you want to
see a simple example of that go to a
farm a regular farm get an egg go to the
grocery store and buying it crack them
both open and just look at the totally
different what do you see yeah one of
them is a little bit darker the the
yolks are a little bit ruptured system
hollering and you've been in it and the
other one just looks like we could have
made it if we had a couple hours yeah
and there you go and the same thing
deals with meat consumption I mean do I
believe that in general meat consumption
is a health risk I do do I
think the China study dr. Colin
Campbell's book about risk for colon
cancer one thing to mention increase
with meat consumption you bet idea I do
but the point is this is asking a person
or large groups of people do you eat
meat or do you not eat meat and a story
you're the one category the other it's
not asking do you eat meat that you get
at the grocery store that came from a
factory where they fed these cattle
garbage genetically modified sprayed
with who knows what antibiotic treated
on and on vs. do you eat meat that's
grass-fed from animals that are roaming
free and not exposed to toxins yeah cuz
traumatic is it because then you're just
getting secondhand inflammation from the
meat a hundred percent you got you you
got that when you nailed it on the head
Jesus man so that's the point that's the
housing how feel and they should write
that on there on the back of the thing
you know Lance was doing well you know
but every day but it would be like
saying we're gonna do a study to
determine if alcohol consumption is good
or bad for your heart and not
determining any difference between
whether you that alcohol comes from a
glass of organic red wine versus some
rotgut Scotch that you buy at a
convenience store right it's all alcohol
no it's not it's all meat no it's not I
see so I think it's really important to
look at this information I think it's
very valid I think Ben's question was
good but having said that we've got to
do a science that looks at quality of
the foods that people are eating okay
would I say that eating eggs from the
grocery store might not be a good choice
yeah I would say that same thing with
the meat I wouldn't I wouldn't eat that
stuff
Wow and I think to be fair more
vegetarian of a diet is a good choice we
are now at a place of one meal a day
being plant-based and moving forward our
next book is talking about OMD one meal
today being plant-based Wow and so now
when you say so people can switch if
they need to from a lot of these because
a lot of people you know we're in
regular towns you know like in my town
growing up like I don't know if I was
there if I would I mean maybe I would
have access to these things first I
would have to seek them out I could
probably get like fresher meat because
there was like a lot of venison and that
sort of stuff it would just have to
a local distributor and find out what
their route is and how they usually go
about delivering stuff but you're saying
that that's a smarter move to organize
something like that than to just be
going to the grocery store I want to
repeat what you just said yeah it was
very important your viewers need to hear
this and that is you're gonna have to
seek it out and that is the difference
between finding time to do something and
making time it's about priority yeah so
if we're gonna prioritize food and we
should prioritize exercise and
prioritize sleep yeah that's the key to
health that's the key to getting rid of
depression it's the key to reducing our
risk for chronic degenerative conditions
moving forward those things have to move
to the top of the list because after all
you know if you don't have your health
then nothing else matters yeah yeah yeah
and we have this there's this feeling
these days you're just gonna cut it's
hard to know it's hard to feel the long
term in the short term you know what I'm
saying you know in my world where you
know a lot of our work deals with
Alzheimer's disease we now recognize as
we talked about a while ago now that the
changes begin in your 20s and 30s and
you don't know that until you listen to
people who are studying that and who are
you know making that information known
let's see about driving right now
hopefully is he's probably stressed if
he is it could be inflammation he's
gonna rage seat his question was related
to dementia hey what's up Theo gang gang
a player here in Daytona for spring
break but I wanted to get my question
and for that guy
bring Kai I forgot his name but anyways
when you go see a doctor a while back
they sent my b12 levels were really
really low so low in fact the guy said
that it contributed to give me a bad
headache since I get migraines and
headaches he said that if I don't start
taking b12 and taking them seriously I
can have early onset dementia in my 30s
yeah
can I ask you a question winter oh oh no
we can't do it's not live okay sorry I'm
sorry dr. Olea we didn't tell you that
yeah people submit these submitted these
yesterday well let's let's respond to
that okay a one would wonder why in the
heck did his doctor check his b12 level
hmm and I would say probably had nothing
to do with his headaches it had to do
with this
I know me technical the size of his red
blood cells okay the lower your red
blood your red cells are the larger I
mean the lower your b12 level is higher
vigorous i0 red blood so because they're
stressed out no it has to do their
construction but but that said he's not
alone there are a lot of people going
around with a low b12 level the brain is
desperate for b12 ow so where'd he get
b12 well you get it from organ meats you
get it from you can get it from
vegetables if the vegetables haven't
been washed like organic vegetables if
they're I say might have a little dirt
on them right so go to these farmers
markets and hit these things up make
that part of your week if you can but
here's the biggest reason I believe that
people have low b12 levels it's because
of the over-usage in our society of
these acid blocking drugs so we need
stomach acid to activate what's called
intrinsic factor intrinsic factor helps
us bind b12 and absorb it everybody
thinks that they have indigestion they
ate some kind of sandwich hums all day
so have all day long you see commercials
the guys trying to eat a sausage
sandwich and the sandwich turns away
from him because they don't get along oh
I remember when I worked in this farm we
would make these like little Tom burgers
we get three of them and stack them
don't tell me that yeah all right so
case in point so when you inhibit
stomach acid you compromise
b12 absorption your b12 level goes down
so okay doctor is giving him
recommending b12 orally
heeey I'm not his doctor right but if a
person at that little b12 level I don't
know if how low it was we would
definitely start with some injections
okay so yeah so that's something you
could also possibly do is you know
whenever you go back to your doctor to
talk about also injections make sure
you're not taking too much calcium or
too many tums or those have antacids
also yeah it's also off the acid yeah
but you need to help process the be
beyond the you know those the calcium
base these these other types of acid
blockers like what well proton pump
inhibitors if I may say thing also drugs
like zantac and nexium yeah and the
pepcid ac over AC of these OTCs
over-the-counter drugs which people take
they everybody thinks because they get
an upset stomach you have to eat some
food they need to BA to pop an antacid
yeah well if you're getting an upset
stomach after you eat of food you sure
as heck shouldn't be eating that food
right here's a mechanism in place that
says if you eat food that's not good for
you you're gonna get an upset stomach
you should pay attention to that not try
to cover it up by taking an acid
blocking drug we need stomach acid
that's what activates our ability to
absorb b12 okay it activates our
digestive enzymes the last thing in the
world you want to do is inhibit your
stomach acid unless you have something
some other issues Olinger Ellison
syndrome four of those tech weenies who
want to know about really get in yeah
yeah yeah that sounds like the damn dark
arts you don't want to tell us no see if
that guy shows up dude we're gonna
probably whoop his ass I'm gonna say
that I'm sorry to you that kind of I
think two guys first of all okay I was a
long time ago oh it's too old one did
somebody yeah that's three can take them
yeah three could take him um you wanna
you have something that we got another
question okay great
hey Theo a David I was wondering as a
neurologist David what's your opinion on
treating depression anxiety etc etc with
psilocybin that's a terrific question so
any question we just lost one of our
comedians a couple weeks ago who ended
up taking his own life and he he hung
himself
I hate to say that because I don't
sounds even grotesque almost saying that
because you know it's but he was even
according to the guy who dropped him off
that evening he was doing as normal as
he ever is he gotten off some medicine
was getting back on without like talking
to his doctor so that's what it seems
like people are equated it to some some
crevasse in that moment mentally where
he just couldn't escape it but anyway
back to his question yeah this is very
pertinent yeah it's an excellent
question
we're seeing some dare I say do we want
to explain yes psilocybin like so it's a
hallucinogen so right okay yeah but
we're seeing with specifically
relationship to psilocybin some there I
say some very positive response in terms
of serious depression and things like
PTSD
I think we're early in the research
though it's been going on a long time
right I think the real dedication to the
research is in its infancy and I'm all
in favor of looking at it further I mean
you know this began in the 60s and 70s
and within the 90s to do it in Covington
Louisiana yeah yeah it was through is it
something you've ever tried have you
ever experimented with psilocybin I've
have I ever tried mushrooms I have yeah
I think did you find it from like in
this did you already have your your
knowledge base so you could kind of
examine it like that or wait I did not I
mean my current knowledge base I know
this was years this was in college it
you know in terms of contextualizing for
me I can't say that it did that in terms
of you know letting me see the world in
a different way I would say it was only
it was momentary mm-hmm
so that said you know I don't know what
the future holds for me but you know
when when you see books now on the New
York Times bestseller list yeah I could
Pollan's book I think that there's a lot
of information there that we need to
look at because I think there is some
value there and yeah the rejection of
hallucinogens from a therapeutic
perspective a perspective was done for
the wrong reasons you know I think the
the declaration the war on drugs and how
that
out of hand during the Nixon era really
set back the possibility as this being
all drugs became this stigma you bet
yeah so I don't take anything off the
table
yeah that's going to help people
especially as it relates to depression
you know anywhere between 40 to 70
percent of suicides are in people who
have significant issues with depression
and let me just make one point that you
will work with your doctor moving
forward unlike what may have happened to
your comedian friend yeah but you know
we'll try to maximize those other things
to give you support in terms of your
lifestyle
young-kyu yeah look I'm excited about
trying this I've tried I tried on one
diet before for a while at camerawoman
paleo opilio for a while and it was good
sometimes I could barely even see though
I think one time I didn't eat for oh
that might have been fasting you fast
for five days I was at a Best Buy
couldn't see but about six feet but I
just really all you need to see it a bit
you buy whatever stairs six feet in your
in your field of vision that's good
enough and go back next year because
what you bought which is actually it you
gotta buy the extended warranty no
matter you whatever you buy you can buy
a USB Drive and they're getting even
extended warranty for 19 years
Oh Ida bought 12 extended feet of site
if I could have been that join 18 feet
who knows what I would have found have
any kind of it wants to minimize the
store it's kind of nice to minimize the
store and make its blue light and I very
much believe I want to suppress it
melatonin so you're dialed in um yeah
you know what I'm even noticing even
when I go out to like if I'm at a bar
club there's a lot more people who are
out on mushrooms in a like in low doses
where's it used to be people were high
or people were drinking it's becoming a
more common thing so I'll see a group of
parens and you know they're just hanging
out and chatting but like oh we took
some mushrooms it's becoming more of a
it's not even if it's experimental but
almost more managed you know the term
micro dosing came out about five years
ago yeah and then it became more man I
felt like people started to see oh this
is more manageable and it's maybe being
delivered and more manageable
supplements so let me then contextualize
my statement and I would say that I am
my statements should not be generalized
to the recreation
we use right but more in terms of a
therapeutic intervention under
supervision yeah I think there's a lot
of a lot of potential there to really
make things happen in a much shorter
period of time
as opposed to years and years of
psychotherapy yeah it has a potential
for that right and that was not a
commentary on the recreational use oh no
I don't think that anybody I don't think
are anybody tell like that but but
thanks for clarifying that Nick did was
there anything else I had a question
yeah sugar is there a real difference
with your body from natural sugars in a
fruit - like refined sugars and you that
agave bad boy I read that a little bit
that's your jam huh you bet yeah so I'm
often asked that question you know what
is you know people say oh I I had honey
that came from bees that meditated every
hour and it's great it's sugar your body
reads it as sugar you know well I'm from
Florida so orange juice is a big thing
there right and a 12 ounce glass of
orange juice it whether it's from
Florida whoever of California is nine
teaspoons of sugar in a 12 ounce glass
of Florida 34 to 36 grams of
carbohydrate in your that's before
you've had your quoi saw or bagel which
are our phantom the jelly on bet and
that's breakfast you're you're in your
blood sugar surges then it crashes in
ten o'clock in the morning you're in
trouble you can't you're back at Best
Buy again or if you sit in front of just
loitering get picked up and so how is
loitering not a disease here there's
some people just I know they like lore
during learning it's a great thing I got
you know to just take in the moment to
be present be much a good point actually
but but that said you know your question
is very good about eating fruit and this
notion of six to eight servings of fruit
a day it's way too much fructose and
glucose you gotta go more green you got
to get on the other side you bet and
you've got fruit juice sorry just to
clarify that's that's freshly squeezed
the look a freshly squeezed orange juice
has the same amount of sugar as
coca-cola
Jesus
what's the mystery here everybody so
yeah but it's got vitamin C I mean
please
you're gonna offset nine teaspoons of
sugar with the 80 milligrams of vitamin
C in terms of being good for you that's
that's the trade-off I don't think so
there's you know have water have
carbonated water have fruit flavored
water there are lots of them out there
right now I just tried a new one and I
thought it was great so we're like for
breakfast man I just don't want to not
be able to eat I mean I feel like it's
gonna be hard what can I eat in well you
might try skipping breakfast really well
you might try having your first meal a
day at noon or one o'clock
yeah I'm smarter if I skip breakfast I
notice my brain works well if you eat
let's say you eat at one o'clock that's
when you so you had dinner the night
before at 7:00 you've gone all that time
fasting then you have a meal that's
called break fast right you broke your
fast at one o'clock in the afternoon
right you build up those ketones you're
stressing your DNA a little bit a
low-grade stress would call that
hormesis amplifying your longevity genes
turning on pathways and our f2 pathway
for those who care to increase your
antioxidant production increased
detoxification decrease inflammation it
is the homerun Wow and who knew I don't
know who invented three meals a day but
somebody one day said three meals a day
that's it if you don't do that I'll be
Bob Evan some if you're gonna Bob Evans
take out some breakfast join but he's
had at least I know Bob Evans I mean
they want her to say for if they could
they would you know the midnight snack
that would be the worst time in the
world to and people get up and have a
bowl of cereal have one last night what
are you so what do you have in the
middle of them if you have to have
something you're hungry you have to have
some no you can't you gotta sleep man
what did you just driving you nuts if I
if I had to that's an emergency
something aside from pee I'd say I would
probably eat half an avocado there you
go yeah I like that maybe feel a little
whole off you take the seed out yeah I
put fill the hole with olive oil and a
little sea salt that's my favorite I can
eat that and be one and done and do my
days but mayonnaise and avocado there
take the middle out put mayonnaise in
that sucker and eat that mission up the
next scene oh yeah guacamole
okay never better no kind of lazy ID but
he would just like put it like a thing
of mayonnaise in there but he was old
till my dad was 70 when I was born he
was an old man Wow
so he had that seniors do I get the same
genes as I would have if my dad was like
35 when I was born well interesting you
get the same genetic code but you there
are nuances of gene expression that
change during a person's life that are
passed on in fact you have changes in
your gene expression that you've
inherited from your grandparents yeah
we've recently seen some studies that
shows significant changes in the
offspring of male mice who've been
exposed to nicotine Jesus Christ so what
you know how we live our lives not only
how we treat our kids but they inherit a
lot of stuff from us if they'll smoke
they'll poke that's what I used to hear
that but if you're trying to meet girls
if they're it was like if you're trying
to pick up girls at a bar or something
it's like oh the smoke the girls that
are smoking or that usually down for
some type of intercourse yeah that's
just an old it apparently pertains to
mice - what else do we want to ask Nicky
give anything I don't have it let me
just said don't necessarily have a
response for that but I'm noodling it
right now gluten-free noodle in my mind
by well you're saying the mice but
nicotine had extra babies is that what
you said no what I said was that there
were changes in DNA expression when mice
were treated with nicotine that were
passed on not only to their offspring
but to their offsprings offspring so Wow
your lifestyle choices are gonna impact
not only your kids but your grandkids
Jesus won't apologize my grandkids right
now for anything I've run yeah it really
is that's what we should leave our the
will should also have a huge disclaimer
you know and by the way here's the poor
choices ah yeah sorry before you rehab
of like a scar fact here's all the poor
choices that I made get the URL for that
there there we go
somebody priority took that it probably
did somebody probably just took it
somebody's probably I have one more
question there's one more video question
I think we should get to UM you
mentioned like the six to eight servings
of fruit and I'm wondering with it like
the food pyramid some is that like some
people have like a theory it's more
nefarious where it's like all lobbies
did that they fought to get there
through this food in there so it's that
it's not just bad science
that we've learned well it's bad science
with all due respect that was put out
bought by industry and so what we
learned published in the Journal of the
American Medical Association in the late
60s and recently recapitulated in the
New York Times front page was that's
incredibly powerful influence that the
sugar industry had over what doctors
would publish in medical journals sinc
that's where all the bad the idea that
fat was bad came from they wanted to
castigate fat so that you would have to
fill in your calories from so sugar and
carb and they manipulated the scientific
data so the doctors bought into this bag
it was published in the New England
Journal of Medicine meanwhile we've now
learned that in the late 60s early 70s
those well-respected researchers were
paid off and that killed hundreds of
thousands if not millions of people
globally because when America adopted
this fatphobia
yeah everywhere around the world
everyone wanted to be like Americans
yeah
and they dropped their dietary fat but
not everybody I mean we saw places for
example like France where they continue
to eat butter they use a lot of olive
oil and their rates of cardiovascular
disease are lower rates of cancer are
lower and to this day it remains that
whether people in various places like
Europe Italy as well eat a lot of fat
you know the Mediterranean diet
everybody that's what I hear about a lot
so great it's a diet that's high fat you
put olive oil on everything look I we
travel with olive oil well and I eat
about a liter a week myself of olive oil
Jesus and the reason we travel is
because when you go to a restaurant most
of the time it's that you say can you
bring me some olive oil it isn't yeah
it's canola they give you canola that
the weird like you think I'm uh put this
on a salad if it's 51% olive oil they're
allowed to say it's olive oil Wow now
it's like if it's fifty one percent
whole grain they're allowed to say this
is whole grain cereal whole grain pasta
whole grain bread do you see those
things starting to chant like are we
going to because I feel as much as a
it's so funny half the day I'll feel
like man we're all [ __ ] we're all
addicted all these foods and all these
things in society's [ __ ] then the
other half of the day I will think you
know what there's such a rebirth of
people learning right
through a long-form entertainment like
podcast yeah instead of just short form
quips that our advertiser supported like
on larger networks right that we're in
an age of enlightenment kind of where if
you want to be enlightened and you want
to learn you still have to take action
physically but if you want to that that
it's there so it's like it's so crazy
half the day I feel one way and half the
day I feel the other the other but isn't
it wild that like it's legal to have so
many other things that are so addictive
but they're not really branded that way
well you know I choose to you know what
I'm saying that oh I absolutely do and I
don't like what I see around me that's
for sure
but you know I I think it's better for
me to light a single candle as opposed
to cursing the darkness I mean I
truthfully you read grain brain there's
a lot of cursing of the dark as that
goes yeah because I don't like what
people do to manipulate you right and
it's unfair and making things addictive
that you would never have suspected yeah
online gambling you know all these like
I was at a casino this weekend and when
I'm in there it's when I thought about I
was like I can't believe I mean the
casino must made 15 million dollars this
weekend alone I was at I was like I just
can't believe that this is legal because
even though it's fun for a little bit
and I get how it the dopamine hits and
stuff and it would seem like it just is
not good for people overall it isn't and
it keeps them locked in where we start
our conversation today keeps them locked
into their reptilian amygdala brain of
impulsivity and not thinking of
consequences people can be addicted to
online shopping you know people like Oh
pornography I mean I'm about 95 days off
of pornography well think about that
that appeals to you instantaneously and
there's then there's a click just like
to go on Amazon buy something instantly
a drink again and here you are you
haven't slept you've traveled and you
see Dunkin Donuts it's playing upon your
susceptibility you are so vulnerable at
that moment and bingo there they are and
I know I shouldn't be eating this crap
but I do yeah because it's there and the
lights and all and
everything and so ah my dark arts you
guys we called the dark arts and we
always have is where they trip where you
were being manipulated into doing
something you don't really want to do
you know or really you know excess you
know that sort of thing well Theo half
the battle is calling it out and so that
that's what our do books about is
calling it out so you can look suddenly
realize these people are taking
advantage of me they are manipulating me
they're manipulating my eyeballs and my
bank account yeah for their advantage
not for you though it's guised as
looking like it's good for you it'll
help you whatever fill in the blank and
that's what I want I want a to lose
weight I want to have a more expensive
car I want a blank they'll help you with
clickbait it's done but in reality it
has nothing to do with you it's all
about them and their bottom line yeah
and our mission is to call it out
because as soon as you recognize it then
you you have different experience with
the bad then suddenly you say hey I'm
not giving in to this right who's in
charge
it's my reptilian brain in charge saying
I'm gonna do it what the heck I have no
control or did CEO finally say huh
not this time I'm gonna make the right
decision yeah cuz I did so funny I like
I like fruity pebbles right now I don't
have an eating them in years right but I
like them but what I like even more is
not getting [ __ ] over by somebody so
once I know then it's like okay I would
eat these but even more so I hate
somebody tricking me or taking advantage
and now that you're aware of that you
can make it change right let me you
bring up an interesting point and that
is fruity pebbles mhm or anything else
that's sweet yeah we love sweet Dew I
love sweet sitting here talking to you
heck yeah what I love to eat sweet foods
why because my brain and your brain and
everybody else on the planet's brain is
wired to like sweet coz sweet told our
ancestors two things it told us that the
food was safe and that the food was ripe
and had the most nutrients it also told
us that there's three things that winter
is coming
linda's fruit generally ripened you know
wild fruit wild blueberries end of the
summer early fall eat sugar what
that do insulin rises what does that do
body fat what does that do lets you
survive in the wintertime where you
don't have food so our sweet tooth led
to our ability to survive now that same
mechanism is being exploited by every
Dunkin Donuts every but everybody that
wants you to eat their free pebbles oh
yeah whatever it is they're appealing to
your sweet tooth that's a dopamine hit
that most people can't turn away from
who knew but you know now that's know I
know I know but I just I wish I didn't
know ah no knowledge is key you know no
it is key it is key even though I don't
want it to be it's like at a certain
point my life I just have to make some
choices that it's like you know I want
to be able to live longer so that I can
you know not only experience life but
also like be a part of good stuff and
like and learn more and like and this is
it it's like I'm starting to see you
know friends I see friends you know I
had a high school reunion a couple years
ago I was like damn this dudes almost
dead you know wait pretty little daniels
almost dead that do look 65 years old
you know he's over there eating paydays
and chilling out you know like you got a
tighten up heath bar see ya here's what
Nico here's what those are good yeah
this is a good thing that's going on
here is here's a guy who you who you're
learning about life and you did the very
best that you can right you're talking
to people you're learning but well
beyond this being just about you you're
sharing this with the hundreds of
thousands of people
who are also having issues trying to
understand what in the heck it's all
about and empowering them with this
knowledge then to make better decisions
the word doctor doesn't mean healer it
means teacher right means giving out
information so you're doing a heck of a
thing here you really are you're helping
a lot of people no thanks man that's
nice you to say yeah we do a lot of
stuff I mean that and our listeners do a
lot of stuff I mean they call them with
real questions you know their concern
they you know I mean I think we are in
this age I think I see it a lot through
our podcast of people wanting to you
know they don't want to be a victim
anymore of you know corporations and of
adverts
and just starting to realize you know I
think some of that is starting to come
to an end in some ways yeah and you know
Thea what it does is it isolates people
ultimately they become just ends of one
walking around on their own isolated
locked into their smartphone and not
interacting yeah and we need everybody
we need you yeah we need everybody to
reconnect to each other so we're
actually in the process of putting
together a website called reconnect
global comm where we're going to have
essays from people who talk about this
how we can reconnect to our gut bacteria
how we can reconnect to the signaling of
our genome how we can reconnect to the
prefrontal cortex and become more
empathetic how I can reconnect to people
around me to people my neighbors to my
community to other countries though they
may be different from us yeah that's
cool how we can connect to the planet
yeah just have some understanding to
want to be healthy to operate at our
fullest because I believe that yeah at
our core we are yeah very good
we have to embrace diversity yeah you
know we talked about of course of the
gut bacteria the more diverse your gut
bacteria the more resilient your body is
to dealing with the onslaught of stress
of our modern world but the more diverse
our culture is same thing the more
diverse you know we are as people the
more were able to handle adversity you
know I had an interesting that's
interesting yeah I had this discussion
with a guy who's involved in Amazon
restoration and preserving the diversity
of the flora and fauna in the in the
Amazon and we realized we're saying the
same thing he's saying we have to
preserve the plants and animals because
diversity is what's going to keep the
Amazon alive and I said same thing with
our microbiome that we have to have
diversity of bacteria to keep us healthy
and we have to have diversity of humans
so that we can be resilient and survive
I see a lot of people you know doing sex
everywhere I go people are you know I
don't even know what color people are
anymore you know so it seems like
there's definitely some good bit of
diversity the more I go around America
yeah and I think yeah like I come from a
culture where you know like mop liar it
was just kind of black and white and
times were a little
different than but now when I go back
home I feel like it's a lot different
vibe and you know I feel like most of
America gets along pretty well it seems
like I think the they politicized that
it's not a lot of places and they
amplify that to me it seems like on the
news but most of the places I go it
doesn't say it's it's not the really the
reality that I see and feel well we are
programmed hardwired to really make a
decision when we see somebody's eyes for
the first time when their face first
time the instantaneous decision is
friend or foe hmm right I could have
Matt yeah Kinzie that instantaneously
friend or foe and we have these then we
color that decision based upon our life
experiences why is that person friend or
foe and I had an interesting experience
that I came off a plane Dallas Texas and
went down the escalator and there was a
woman wearing a burka and it was right
after a terrorist thing that happened
and you know as we all do friend or foe
and I my mind said foe mmm you know step
back this person and I realized that
that's an impulse from my amygdala it's
an instantaneous impulse
I am absolutely going to override that
impulse and recognize it for what it was
and do my very best to override that
yeah and speak to people and it's the
same thing yeah like you're saying its
diversity way it's like same thing with
making the choices that we put in our
stomach it's making the choices that we
see in front of us just taking a moment
and and Trust in our instinct when we
prejudge that's the definition of pred
Judas comes from and we prejudge based
upon these engrams that are built up in
our minds from early life experiences
that you know to a significant rare
place there by our parents and what they
thought you know what their world was
like right and when I grew up you know
the world was we were doing we were not
taught but things were very polarized oh
yeah have to do our very best to embrace
diversity and just open up our hearts
yeah and yeah you know the amygdala is
gonna make a decision we don't have to
go with that decision if the amygdala
says I'm gonna reach out I'm gonna buy
I'm gonna do this I'm gonna eat this we
take a step back
we bring online a higher level of
thinking and we ask ourselves is this an
appropriate decision right am i is
literally manipulate yeah I might be a
manipulated him I'll just lizard in
probiotics what is that because I
started taking those eat chewing those
the gummies they're not like a man
well you liked them what do you mean
like them I like them I feel like they
are good okay having a little snow you
could say there you go you could say I
like them most I ever had was four okay
okay you could say I liked them from the
amygdala meaning I like them because
they're sweet and I like that and I'm
done
yeah the chewable ones or you could say
I like them because that's what I want
to know what I like do you like them
because you bring your prefrontal cortex
a I like them because I now know that
having probiotic organisms in my gut
helps with diversity helps with a gut
function helps reduce inflammation and
I'm buying into that science yes having
said that then probably the gummy part
of the probiotic gummy would not be the
way to go so you're eating them because
you they're a little treat yeah you're
not but you know I mean I want to have
probiotics I'm you know I started
thinking like I got to make my stomach
healthier you know so you want to get a
good probiotic and there's some good
brands but we can talk about but you
want to get one that has long shelf life
okay that gives you 30 40 50 billion
organisms there's a lot of diversity of
organisms 10 like a damn aquarium inside
of me I'm more than that yeah so you
really want to look for those factors in
there plenty of good products out there
but I think that's a very reasonable
thing and then be sure that you cultured
these guys as well as the ones that
already live in there by having lots of
prebiotics in your diet
okay and you can get some great
probiotics from eating fermented foods
like kimchi and sauerkraut and fermented
vegetables so you don't have to always
buy a probiotic pill or in this case
gummy okay I you may want to pass in the
gummies I mean I'm not trying to be
brand specific here I don't know but
like say if you're in a bind and you get
in a tough spot can some probiotic
gummies help you out uh yeah I I don't
know how bioavailable those probiotics
are gonna be right so you really again
you want to look for certain parameters
within you know that brands are gonna
satisfy making sure you
really getting what you're what you
think you are okay but I understand that
if you're eating the gummies you're
eating the gummy part not the probiotic
part probably right you think you're
some probiotics and there they have to
put something no you know there's no
there's no oversight as far as that goes
who looks at that and says yeah not only
are they in there generally read the
label and often as what they're gonna
say is 10 billion CFU meaning colony
forming units at the time of manufacture
well if you see that that's not the
product for you right you don't want
something that when they manufactured it
18 months ago had this now it's got
nothing with that fresh hitter you want
to have some that says 30 billion CF use
guaranteed for 12 months after the date
that is stamped on that product when it
was manufactured so you take it six
months later it's been on the store
shelf you had at home and now it's still
gonna kick your butt in terms of having
good probiotics and so eating better
will leave me more to be my best self
there's really just no denying it it
seems like it's a take-home message but
it's all about taking that moment bring
it online your higher level of thinking
about what's best for Theo and who's in
charge and what are my instincts what
are those that are in my stomach
so instincts are some things that are
programmed suite is an instinct okay sex
is an instinct okay you know a feast
flight against potentially it's
threatening in for issue is an instinct
so you know we talked about trust your
instincts people say well trust your
instincts to some degree but sometimes
our instincts can get us into trouble
you know somebody says something to you
and you punch them in the face
instinctually well they may even talk to
the guy standing behind you right right
or they may have thought you were some
whatever right and so that's an
instinctual response and amygdala based
sudden reaction that we need to temper I
think back I mean the I I'll never
forget Santa in a line of all places at
Best Buy oh yeah
no it was Costco it was Costco and I had
an instinctual response that I
gret and i you could say what you want
to me I'm okay with that
but somebody said something to my wife
and like it didn't luckily it could have
been worse but and I was I have to say I
was right down on myself for not raining
that and I should have been the bigger
person and rained it in then I didn't
and but it's a lesson so so sometimes as
instinctive responses can harm you yeah
and instinctually we should eat sugar
all the time because instinctually we
are told that it is good for us as
telling us winter's coming and that the
fruit is safe and ripe that's we
override that with our higher core
function telling us no we don't want to
eat a lot of sugar instinctually
everybody wants to have sex with
everybody yeah and no matter what and
you know you can't do it you know modern
society and law not necessarily gonna be
good for you oh you can't even
masturbate in your car anymore around
here can you pour down there used to be
a ton I was aware of that but so
something happened in lining you got an
altercation yeah it could have been a
lot worse
and anyway but that was your instincts
it was my instinct but I checked it
right at the right moment and and I
actually think a sensei a teacher from
years ago martial arts teacher who
worked with me with that that got me to
the level and what would kind of
actually would hit me in the face until
I and would intent me from responding
and would say something you want to hit
me back come on hit me back and training
me not to respond and I got to that
point and that Engram was activated and
then I back down and it was very
grateful for that training because it
took me the edge you know it's funny
because I had an experience I was in I
think Berlin one time with the
girlfriend we were traveling and and we
were on this bike tour you know you're
gonna bike tours we sure the tourists
sometimes and some guy was like going
down a bike path really fast and he like
hit my girlfriend's bike like really
hard and when I looked at him I could
tell immediately he'd like done it on
purpose I weren't really in the way he
had maybe he got angry with tourists he
didn't like living in the city
who knows but my first instinct was to
pedal off and [ __ ] kill that guy you
know get a knife out an imaginary knife
suddenly in my hand like I was gonna
[ __ ] kill this dude you know but I
didn't right I didn't do that I just
stayed there you know I made sure she
was okay but I've always regretted no no
I don't maybe not killing but at least
driving over and jumping and just you
know tackling him in at least but think
about it now from the perspective of the
fact that you were able to rein yourself
in that is absolutely huge think about
mad though that you could rein yourself
in at that moment and not do you could
rein in the amygdala and say I'm not
gonna do it and that should be a sense
of pride that you had I felt like it was
a wimp I felt like a wimp though no
you're not a wimp you know that you need
that man to prove that you're a wimp or
not a wimp
who is he how should he enter into your
life
hopefully dead I wish but but yeah but
yeah I mean yeah I gotta let it go I
guess I still have a resentment against
that man so glad I feel it so it's good
to take yourself out of the moment
and experience it that was what that
deep breath was just about because you
went back to that moment and it again
challenged you you know your adrenaline
level is up Quartus cortisol levels up
fight-or-flight which isn't necessarily
good for you but to let it go to feel it
experience it take that purging breath
clearing breath and move on you're a
better person for that and the fact that
you rained it in then that is HUGE you
pat yourself on the back for that one
pat that dude on the back really hard
with a knife and anything else that you
have oh yeah so we have six doctors
pretty doctors right Nick via field this
one out here yeah we've got six
celebrity doctors and we'd like you to
rank them just in your your your love
for them your respect for them and for
the people listening we've got Deepak
Chopra dr. ken Jeong dr. drew dr. oz Che
Guevara and dr. Phil who should we
listen to you know yeah well to light
their single candle and not anyway I
fight the dark I love Deepak
I've known Deepak for
I guess 28 years I dreamed about Deepak
Chopra last night
oddly enough and this morning I told my
wife I dreamed about Deepak we were
having dinner I
I think he's centered I think he's one
of the coolest individuals I know so I
love the guy number one well let me let
me consider that what they will work on
the ranking member das is fantastic I'm
a medical adviser to the dr. Oz Show
been on that program I guess three or
four times I I respect his desire to be
a little bit out there to challenge the
mainstream and to really apply a level
of objectivity to things that are a
little bit off center and I highly
respect that I know him as a person and
his wife and his wife's parents
is he a neat man he's a cool guy Wow I
like him a lot and we actually just were
with his mother and father-in-law two
weeks ago in New York and they're
terrific people dr. drew super cool I
mean here's the job - yeah he is
I respect everything he's about as
inquisitive mine is breathtaking
his depth of knowledge but depth of
validation when he has an idea I think
is super cool yeah the other three I
don't know who's top middle there that's
dr. ken Jeong he's now a comedian and
comedic actor but oh that's right he was
a doctor I only know him from the comedy
perspective yeah doctor wasn't going so
good if he bailed out yeah but
apparently this part is working out well
I've heard him on the comedy channel so
or one of the serous radio channel
channels so from that perspective I
respect his comedy che guevara I'm not
sure I you know I think we're kind of in
a different arena and with all due
respect I think that dr. Phil might be
in a different arena
not being a medical doctor but then
again you know the things that both good
is not a doctor of he was a bouncer
wasn't he on the Oprah show well he know
his show is all about psychology oh
that's so you know both Deepak and Mimi
RMDs Deepak was an endocrinologist very
well credentialed Mehmet Oz practice
cardiovascular surgery as you may know
so my ability to relate to them on my
based on my training I think is much
greater and but you know clearly they
both are exploring areas that are not
particularly in the field of medicine
but absolutely should be like
spirituality in the case of Deepak and
certainly Mehmet go set place as well so
what can I say I believe the answer at
that who do you think set you a lot of
dr. Oz and dr. Drew who what whose sex
here you think well III don't know what
what kind of shape dr. oz is and I think
he's lean and mean dr. Drew dedicates
himself to that he's ripped
III I don't know I I think Deepak is
sexy actually I've hi I did because a
Deepak does what he wants he wears what
he wants and I think and I I think he's
very attractive from from the
perspective of of being artsy in that
regard and I find artsy to be very
attractive yeah there you go deep pocket
is man dr. Perlmutter thank you so much
for being here and yeah I think it's
been really really interesting thanks
for you oh I got a year of dieting that
idea is gonna a lifetime
[Music]
but when I reach that round I'll share
this piece of my I can feed it enough
thought it's gonna take
a little time for me to set that parking
brake
and let myself
[Music]